Speaker 1: After notching some wins last week, the
failed former president Donald Trump has a pretty
serious endorsement failure on his hands now
as the alleged serial groper Charles Herb store
has suffered a primary defeat. Although Trump
did get a win in West Virginia last night,
so we're going to talk about it as well as
the implications. The big news, of course,
Trump backed Herb ster accused of groping loses
to pillion in Nebraska. That was the Nebraska
gubernatorial money wins in West Virginia.
The mixed results for Trump came in contests
pitting him against local Republican leaders. As
a reminder, here is Donald Trump talking about
the great Charles Herb Stirrer Cruz
accused of groping at least eight women.
Speaker 2: In return to Charles. A good man. You
go there and you understand it in true American
history in you see.
Speaker 1:
The audio at that event clearly run by Antifa,
as you can tell. But we could tell what Trump was
saying, which is he is endorsing Herb Stirrer and
Herb Store is good and Herb Store is going to win.
But sadly for him, herbs, they're lost.
The results are that Jim Pilling has won
the Republican primary in Nebraska for the
gubernatorial race. Jim Pilling It was close.
It was close, basically 34 to 30 with a third
candidate, Brett Lindstrom, coming in at roughly
26% with just the Omaha area. So that is a defeat
for Donald Trump. What are the takeaways? Well,
interesting article from The New York
Times. One takeaway is Trump still did
get a win in West Virginia. On paper, West
Virginia's new second congressional district
should have given an advantage to McKinley, who
previously represented a larger area seeking a
seventh term. But Mooney, 50 years old, who once
led the Republican Party in neighboring Maryland,
romped across nearly the entire district.
Trump's endorsement is widely seen as powering
the Mooney campaign in one of the states where the
former president has been more pop most popular.
Trump also referring to McKinley as a I'm
sorry, Mooney, referring to McKinley as a RINO,
which has been a popular attack for Donald
Trump. So so far this primary season,
you know, the J.R. Magoo ski thing is complicated
because J.R. Maju ski pledged loyalty to Trump. He
was on his knees for Trump praying at the altar of
Trump. But Trump didn't actually endorse Maju ski.
But after Maju ski one, Trump said like, Hey, I
didn't even really know about this guy, but he's
a Trump guy and he's great. So now sort of like
an endorsement going into the general. But listen,
Trump's record so far is pretty good, 75%,
roughly, depending on how you calculate it.
And the reason we care about this is not so
much because Trump claims he has a perfect
endorsement record when it's really a pretty
average endorsement record over the last five
years. That's not actually why we care about this.
We care about this because we know that among
whether Trump is in a lot of legal trouble
and whether Trump has health problems,
that another factor that will influence whether
Trump tries to run again in 2024 is whether he
perceives that he can easily win, at minimum
the Republican nomination, if not the general.
And one of the ways that he and we and others will
be able to ascertain whether he's got a shot at
the Republican nomination, at minimum, is whether
his endorsement continues to carry significant
weight in the 2022 midterms. And so far, it's
certainly carrying some weight. In fact, I would
even venture to say it's very early, but so far,
Trump's record in 2022 is better than his overall
record over the last few years. It's very early.
We have only a handful of races and over the next
month and really over the next yeah, roughly the
next four or five weeks, we're going to have a
number of additional primaries. Trump putting out
a series of endorsements yesterday on his website,
and many of them are incumbents. So, you know,
when is it really a big win if you endorse an
incumbent and the incumbent wins? I would argue
no, but all of it is what can you justify? What
can you convince your followers of? And so far,
Trump is doing okay. Although, I mean, listen,
going with the eight times accused serial groper
in Nebraska, maybe it was destined not to go
particularly well. Now later, we're going to
talk about Elon Musk saying that if he finishes
his purchase of Twitter, he would unbanned Donald
Trump from the platform. I'll give my thoughts on
that later. Merely anecdotally, I kind of would
love to see what Trump would be tweeting about
his Herbstreit endorsement right now. If he were
on Twitter, he would probably be saying something
like, Were it not for the fake, phony, fraudulent
allegations of groping, I would have gotten the
endorsement win. But the left made it up and now
you know, something like that. That's my guess of
what Trump would be saying about this race if he
were on Twitter. But it's good that Herbst or lost
Herbst was a disaster. And the fact that it's a
loss for Trump just makes it a little bit better.